shall we begin
I can't forget what I saw north of the
wall I can't pretend that Circe wanted
to take back half the country the moment
I marched North your grace everyone you
know will die before winters over if we
don't defeat the enemy to the north as
far as I can see you are the enemy to
the north
and I've already pledged myself to Queen
Daenerys of House Targaryen
[Music]
when people ask you what happened here
tell them the North remembers
tell them winter came for house free
[Music]
you [ __ ] Teeter lower you stand accused
of murder
you stand accused of treason how do you
answer these charges Lord Baelish John
isn't really my father's son he's the
son of Rhaegar Targaryen and my aunt
Lyanna Stark
whatever stands in our way we will
defeat ourselves fives for this
who would you say is the father yeah
we have something to show you
the darkness is coming for us all
face it together you pledged our forces
to fight our coming let's say whatever I
need to say to ensure the survival of
our house no one walks away from me
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
fiora
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]